bah mon âge c'est quoi les risques de me
retrouver à l'hôpital tout le monde peut
se retrouver à l'hôpital c'est pas
seulement de te protéger toi mais aussi
les autres en août 2021 pour encourager
sa population à ce vacciner le ministère
de la santé en France a créé un spot TV
qui conclut comme suit on peut débattre
de tout sauf des chiffres aujourd'hui en
France 8 personnes sur 10 hospitalisées
à cause du covid ne sont pas vaccinés
tous vaccinés tous protégés de la même
façon ensuite le conseiller d'État va
les en Mathias Reynard signa le fait que
90% des hospitalisés ne sont pas
vaccinés ces statistiques sont ainsi
utilisées pour insister sur l'importance
et l'efficacité de la vaccination et
j'imagine que beaucoup de provaces parmi
vous l'aurait retweeté si vous étiez sur
Twitter et si vous avez vu ce chiffre
cependant aujourd'hui je vais essayer de
vous convaincre que ce genre de
statistiques est en fait très
problématique à partager non pas parce
qu'elle est erronée mais parce qu'elle
est en fait trompeuse en particulier
elle ne permet pas du tout de conclure
directement à l'efficacité du vaccin et
donc à l'importance de se faire vacciner
en tout cas pas toute seul pire encore
dans les mois à venir surtout en France
ou la couverture vaccinale grandit la
mise en avant de telles statistiques
veut même probablement conduire à un
chaos informationnel peut-être même
statistique pourrait bientôt donner
l'impression que ce vacciner est
dangereux pour la santé ce qui va
ensuite probablement conduire à un chaos
informationnel et à l'approche des
élections avec de telles habitudes au
risque fort d'assister à la popularité
de mouvements très mal informés au
triomphe des campagnes de désinformation
et potentiellement même à des révoltes
violentes dangereuses
si vous avez suivi cette série vous
m'avez entendu répéter l'expression
suivante la vraie semblance des données
n'est pas la crédence de la théorie ou
dit autrement la probabilité de donner
des sachant une théorie t il est en
général pas du tout égal à la
probabilité inverse de la théorie t
sachant les données des de façon plus
générale pour toute variable A et B la
probabilité de a sachant B n'est pas
égale à la probabilité inverse de B
sachant a et dans le cas des vaccinés
hospitalisés cette distinction est
absolument critique à avoir en tête en
effet notamment dans un pays où le taux
de vaccination est très élevé comme
c'est de plus en plus le cas en France
il faut en fait s'attendre à ce que la
probabilité d'être vaccinée sachant
qu'on est hospitalisé soit élevé alors
que la probabilité inverse d'être
hospitalisée sachant qu'on est vacciné
restera faible ou dit autrement ce qu'il
va probablement finir par arriver c'est
que la plupart des vaccinés ne seront
jamais hospitalisés quand bien même la
plupart des hospitalisés seront vaccinés
et le jour où ça va arriver
ça va être la cacophonie avec des
arguments moisi de partout le tout
appuyé par des statistiques parfaitement
factuelles mais trompeuses surtout avec
les élections présidentielles et des
candidats qui vont constamment chercher
à plaire à leur électorat d'ailleurs de
tels chiffres ont déjà été constatés
dans le cas d'Israël ou le taux de
vaccination est un 90 % chez les
personnes âgées et où la majorité des
hospitalisés sont des personnes
vaccinées et oui en Israël 6
hospitalisés sur 10 sont vaccinés mais
clairement ce taux de vacciné parmi les
hospitalisés est un très mauvais chiffre
à communiquer car il est si facile de
mal interpréter et malheureusement les
sceptiques de l'efficacité vaccinale ou
les campagnes de désinformation qui
veulent affaiblir un pays ennemi vont
probablement se faire une joie de
relayer massivement de telles
statistiques or comme on va le voir très
banquet ou des bonnes quai ces
statistiques de vacciner parmi les
hospitalisés c'est déjà horriblement
difficile même auprès de gens assez à
l'aise en maths et suffisamment en mode
explorateur pour réfléchir calmement
surtout que dans les mois à venir il n'y
aura pas uniquement cette statistique à
des bunker tellement de chiffres
circulent venant de tellement de pays au
contexte différent quand Thierry piquant
à gauche et à droite on peut trouver
toutes sortes de statistiques qui
suggèrent tout et son contraire en
exploitant typiquement la confusion
omniprésente entre une probabilité
conditionnelle P2A sachant B et ne
probabilité inverse P de B sachant a
quand on sait que même des scientifiques
et même des statisticiens ont un mal fou
à distinguer la probabilité de a sachant
B de la probabilité de B sachant a on
est vraiment mal barré et oui pour
rappel ce sophisme et même au cœur de la
méthode scientifique par PV value et
bien sûr dans les mois à venir on risque
aussi d'assister à des interviews de
gens qui ne voulaient pas être vaccinés
mais qui à cause des circonstances se
sont senties contraint d’être vaccinés
et qui ont néanmoins dû être hospitalisé
avec possiblement des séquelles à long
terme ces personnes risquent alors fort
de témoigner de l'inutilité des vaccins
probablement avec un esprit
contestataire le tout sur BFM TV ou
iTele et ça ça peut monter en flèche
dans les mois à venir et influencer
ensuite les positionne politique et là
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe bref comme vous le
comprenez je suis très loin d'être
confiant pour le futur à moins d'effort
massif pour soutenir l'information de
qualité sa production et surtout ça
recommandation les crises épistémique
risque de continuer à avoir des
conséquences dramatiques à la fois sur
le plan médical mais aussi en termes de
géopolitique d'environnement et de
justice sociale
bon c'est bien beau de se plaindre de la
mise en formation mais il ne suffit pas
de la noyer pour la combattre si on veut
améliorer le niveau épistémique il est
critiques de parvenir à mieux réfléchir
soi-même et à aider les autres à mieux
réfléchir et donc pour finir cette vidéo
je vais essayer de vous faire sentir la
raison pour laquelle la probabilité de
assombé peut être très différente de la
probabilité inverse de B sachant a le
tout pour que vous ayez davantage le
réflexe de vous demander si une
statistique du genre beaucoup de baies
sont a et vraiment ce qui les pertinent
de constater et de partager je vous
propose de commencer par avoir des
exemples en tête pour essayer de
travailler notre intuition instinctive
en particulier pour cela je vous invite
vivement à revoir l'épisode 21 on avait
vu que la plupart des musulmans ne sont
en fait pas des Arabes quand bien même
la plupart des Arabes sont effectivement
musulmans en effet il est vrai que
certains arabes ont d'autres religions
certains sont ratés d'autres sont
catholiques mais ceux-ci sont rares
parmi les Arabes la plupart des Arabes
sont musulmans néanmoins la plupart des
musulmans ne sont pas arabes et ça c'est
parce qu'il y a énormément énormément de
gens en Asie et qu’une fraction certes
faible mais non négligeable d’entre eux
sont musulman notamment en Indonésie en
Chine ou en Inde gardez bien cet exemple
en tête la plupart des Arabes sont
musulmans mais la plupart des musulmans
ne sont pas rares et si on se demande
pourquoi et bien c'est pas mal parce
qu'il y a énormément de gens notamment
en Asie qui ne sont pas musulmans mais
ne sont pas rares particuliers il y en a
beaucoup plus que de gens qui sont
arabes autre exemple que je vous propose
de garder en tête qui est un exemple que
j'ai mentionné dans l'épisode 22 la
plupart des prix Nobel aime le chocolat
mais la plupart de ceux qui aiment le
chocolat n'ont pas de prix Nobel et si
c'est le cas c'est parce que de façon
encore plus massive il y a énormément de
gens qui aiment le chocolat et non pas
de prix Nobel beaucoup plus que de gens
qui ont un prix Nobel enfin je vais
rajouter un troisième exemple
ultra classique qui est celui des tests
médicaux imparfaits pour des maladies
très rares comme on parle d'ailleurs
fribourne veritacium ou encore Monsieur
Philippe même si un test est valide à
99%, si la maladie ne touche qu'une
personne sur un million alors les
malades ont presque tous un test positif
mais ceux qui ont un test positif sont
quasiment tous non malades voilà je vous
invite à vraiment méditer ces exemples
en tête car le problème des hospitalisés
vaccinés est exactement le même en
particulier de la même façon on Israël
la plupart des hospitalisés sont
vaccinés mais la quasi-totalité des
vaccinés ne sont pas hospitalisées tout
ça parce qu'il y a énormément de gens
qui sont vaccinés et ne sont pas
hospitalisés beaucoup plus que de gens
qui sont hospitalisés et pour bien que
cette distinction entre propriorités de
A à Champé et la probabilité de B
sachant a devient absolument un réflexe
pour retintuition instinctive je vous
invite à le rechercher par vous même
d'autres exemples encore c'est souvent
beaucoup plus efficace pour retenir un
principe si on parvient à trouver
soi-même un exemple marquant qui
l'illustre parfaitement
pour les gens un peu plus mateux parmi
vous je vous propose une explication
plus fine de ce phénomène qui fait appel
au curseur de Turing ça va vous demander
un peu plus d'efforts mais si vous
saisissez très bien le curseur de Turing
alors vous pourrez résoudre beaucoup
plus de paradoxes apparent qu'avec une
poignée d'exemples représentatives d'un
4 précis rappelez-vous le curseur de
Turing permet d'appliquer rigoureusement
la formule de base dans un cas où il n'y
a que deux théories à comparer et là ça
tombe bien dans notre cas on a envie de
comparer les cas pas vaccinés et le cas
vacciné pour un individu donné mettons
donc pas vacciner et vacciné à chaque
bout d'une droite la position initiale
du curseur représente ensuite la
probabilité qu'un Français tirait au
hasard soit vacciné au fil des mois ce
curseur n'a cessé de se déplacer vers la
droite puisque le taux de vaccination a
augmenté et en fait sachant que fin août
parmi 100 français il y avait 63
personnes ayant reçu deux doses et 28
néanmo su aucune dose on est même à un
peu plus de 1 bits du côté de la
vaccination ok maintenant essayons
d'estimer la probabilité qu'une personne
soit vaccinées sachant qu'elle est
hospitalisée pour cela il faut estimer
comment la donner la personne et
hospitalisée déplace le curseur de
Turing et ça ça dépend de ce que j'ai
appelé le rapport de surprise autrement
dit à quel point devrions-nous être
davantage ou surpris par
l'hospitalisation d'un individu sachant
qu'il est vacciné par opposition à
sachant qu'il n'est pas vacciné alors je
vous épargne les détails de calcul mais
cette question est en fait directement
reliée à l'efficacité du vaccin pour un
vaccin efficace à 89%, la surprise de
l'hospitalisation en cas de vaccination
est 9 fois plus grande que la surprise
en cas de non vaccination bon il y a des
subtilités derrière cette notion
d'efficacité vaccinale et on y reviendra
d'ailleurs dans la prochaine vidéo or un
facteur de neuf ça correspond à un peu
plus de 3 bits d'information en
déplaçant le curseur de 3 bits dans la
direction de la théorie qui explique
mieux l'hospitalisation on constate que
a posteriori le curseur de Turing penche
deux bits en faveur de la
non-vaccination ou dit autrement on
s'attend alors à soit quatre fois plus
probable qu'un hospitalisé soit vacciné
que non vacciné ou dit encore autrement
sur 5 hospitalisés 4 ne devraient pas
être vaccinés ce qui correspond
d'ailleurs au chiffre actuellement en
France ok mais notamment suite au
passage sanitaire il faut s'attendre à
ce que le taux de vaccination augmente
dans les mois à venir en France
imaginons que désormais 90% des Français
sont doublement vaccinés contre 10% de
non vaccinés désormais a priori avant de
savoir si un individu est hospitalisé le
curseur de Turing penche de 3,2 bits en
faveur de la vaccination mais alors à
posteriori après le déplacement de 3,2
bits dû à la donnée l'individu est
hospitalisé on se retrouve à zéro
autrement dit si 90% des Français sont
doublement vaccinés et si le vaccin est
efficace à 90%. alors parmi les
hospitalisés il y aura autant de
vaccinés que de non vaccinés et alors je
précise quand même que mon analyse ici
est en fait trop simplifié notamment
qu'à l'omet de nombreux facteurs de
confusion comme l'âge de la personne ces
antécédents médicaux et son application
des gestes barrières si les personnes
âgées sont plus vaccinées si les
personnes avaient déjà infecté sont
vaccinent moins et si les vaccinés
prennent moins soin de leur gestes
barrière alors il faut s’attendre à ce
que la plupart des hospitalisés soient
vaccinés et ce même si le vaccin demeure
efficace à
90%. autant dire que en fait oui les
statistiques sur les nombres de vaccinés
parmi les hospitalisés ça se débat mais
le problème c'est que pour bien en
débattre et bien il faut connaître un
minimum de statistiques